[Applause]
that's legal I can actually come across
and just whack you as hard as they can
you can knock the guy out my name is
I've been in Japan for the past 40 years
I joined Sumo 1982 so I've been in the
circuit for 16 years as a professional
Sumotori today we'll be looking at some
Sumo scenes from movies and see how rare
it is through my eyes
that man is
the greatest fighter in Japan but he's
so tiny it's very real his name is Mike
Umi he's actually a real professional
that's the thing that a lot of Americans
or a lot of foreigners don't know the
professional Sumo League our
professional which is only one in the
world we don't have any weight class
it's not wrestling it's it's you just
um translating the word into sumo
wrestling where we call it Sumotori but
we don't even call it a sport it's more
like a culture is a movement smaller
combatant uses to throw the larger men
of Barracks so like how the actor
explaining he's going to use a
hatakikumi which is a technique used by
a smaller Sumotori we have like
different techniques in subo and the
reason for that is because it's taking
advantage by the smaller guys the bigger
guys is about strength and power and
then how you move your weight and stuff
but the smaller guys that are tricky is
like they kick your feet they pull your
hands they twist your elbows and it's
very dangerous and salt is uh used very
much in the Japanese culture if you go
to many uh shrines or temples in Japan
you're going to notice that there's
certain places that put salt just to
purify and there's a thing in the
Japanese culture when you go to
someone's funeral when you go back they
give you these envelopes there's salt in
it so what it does is uh chase away bad
spirits before you walk into your home
and sumoto is used to use the salt to
actually bless their rings every single
day
look there the hair you see during that
tournament they call it oicho oicho is
for um for only High rankers what we
regularly wear is what you see the
Samurai movies like uh uh chomunge if
you go bald I noticed they're doing
extensions this is why you can separate
the Sumotori from any other professional
sport because we have to dress like them
you're not allowed to wear any of this
you get caught wearing something like
they'll probably kick you out right away
so you have to walk the streets with
kimonos during the winter and then you
cut them what we call is a lighter
material and we have to worry what we'll
we'll set those are called slippers the
centers we wear we can tell what rank
you are just by looking at the rep and
from the slippers you were
it's a pull down this technique is used
by a smaller opponent because it's all
about speed and timing but what he's
trying to do is just to beat you to make
you come forward and push your weight
forward fast enough where he can time it
where he just drill to show you so that
technique itself is uh well used I
wouldn't use it because by the time I do
it it probably hit my belly because I'm
pulling down it's a very winning move
for that type of sumoturi
this is such a cool clip the way you see
it udoyo which is the Sumo ring if you
look at the way that it's built those
days they used to have the pose on the
corner to hold up the top during my
career we still had that not in a major
tournament but during our tours the
thing I like about the scene it makes it
so like um authentic the way they built
that Stadium I would like to see it go
back to that and make it lesser because
right now you gotta imagine we have six
major tournaments a year in Japan and
there's 12 000 people there 15 days in a
row and that is crazy because they're
using two real sumotories and this is is
beautiful I think I give him a 10. I
wish I could wrestle with that era the
way it's built around the ring itself
and very authentic
[Applause]
what you just seen is exactly what they
were doing in that tournament or during
the match they have a thing what we call
chili Jose which is they come up and
they do a ceremony where they slap their
hands and they do all this this is a
another tradition that for us to respect
our opponent to show him that I left my
double barrel at home I ain't gonna
shoot you I'm going to beat you up with
my own hands it's that kind of thing
the referee doesn't say [ __ ] you gotta
touch all fours the hands have to touch
he just has eye contact so that's what
makes Sumas a very unique too if you're
running a 100 yard dash somebody pushed
the guns or even a boxing match the Bell
Rings right but this is all eye contact
it's a funny clip the motions and
everything is kind of real but the
throws are that wouldn't happen noon it
would only happen in a a Superman move
those throwing techniques you're going
to see some guys get like flip-flipped
like backflip like you know that can
really happen the word for what
technique they used means it's today's
match Commodities he forced out is just
the meaning of that
that is very rude one of these two guys
are supposed to be a grand champion if
your grand champion gets his ass kicked
so people would actually throw their
zavu dongs it's those pillows that they
sit on at the tournaments and you see
this even till today it's tradition the
people watching on the side on the floor
get hurt some people think it's just
good luck even though they go to the
hospital with broken bones but because
of sumatologists are trained so well we
learn how to break Falls no one really
gets hurt falling off the ring
everything is more like elbow or Twisted
knees a six or seven six point five
seven is good it's good
[Applause]
very very good the guy has the fence
what we call ayobirashi which is a ring
color the other guy who has the panel
he's his hand is called gyoji which is
the referee every Sumo stable has one of
each those positions too are ranked you
have like from the lowest rank to the
highest rank the drums would never be
there but that's the only thing that I
wouldn't see in a in a regular Sumo
tournament
[Music]
that is very normal the shikoi is a
squatting that they do where they lift
up their legs and pound their legs down
that's what because so that's the sumo
squat that's what they do to stumble
away the bad spirits on the ring your
first six months all you do is go you do
like a thousand a day easy that's the
best exercise to strengthen your legs
and actually straighten up your core but
I think because of the exercises we do
it helps prevents injuries it loosen up
your hips and stuff like that you can
get lower
this is exactly what you would see at a
Sumo match actually we can go and
actually broke your elbow in one move
what the guy just did he can step out of
what what we do use my able to clamp
down on his on his hand that's on me and
all I have to do is twist in and twist
down I can break his elbow so my fingers
are broken from that because we learned
how to cut your hand off the belt when
you grab it and there's like four or
five different ways to take the belt off
your hand it's very easy to break your
fingers
that's legal I can actually come across
and just whack you as hard as I can you
can knock a guy out because it's a
karate chop the mixture of martial arts
Aikido and karate and actually I can
broke your nose with my hand with my
pump which I did during my career so
people don't know that part
[Music]
to win a summer match is simple it's 5.5
meters that round circle you have 5.5
meters to work with so the object of the
game is to push you up on an outer ring
or throw him into the ring anything but
the bottom of his feet touches the floor
you lose the mat so it sounds easy but
having guys over 400 pounds going
against each other pushing weight they
can try to take advantage of weight
shifting and stuff like that it's not as
easy as it looks I would rate it a nine
just to jump six thousand point away but
it's it's a very good clip
that's the ranking this is the second
highest is the champion before they had
Grand Champion Yokozuna the only the
highest rank was only ozeki in the olden
days never been done by any Foreigner
bro I'm the first to ever do that and um
it's a shocking to the Sumo world or to
the country because no one has done it
before and I was very fortunate to be in
the right time right place right mind
physical through to handle the sport
[Applause]
[Music]
it's the best protein called it
changonabe that's how they put our
weight on it's very very nutritious
they're very very healthy too it can be
chicken can be pork it can be beef get a
mixture of different meats can be Fish
seafood so that changes every single day
you don't have the same menu at all you
have to be very healthy because they
check on your body if you're diabetic or
they won't take you they check your
heart every like twice a year they're
very uh crucial about being healthy
because to be big and to grow bigger you
have to have a healthy body to handle
all the eating too
no
no
you got a 10 on that one he's actually
getting introduced to a stable that he's
going to join and your guests until you
come officially a Sumotori so he's
getting treated as a VIP which everybody
get treated if you're not a sumoto and
you're invited to come to a Sumo stable
get used to it because they'll be
serving you until you leave
a building bro everybody lives there and
everything is in there there's the
practice areas in there the shower rooms
are huge the kitchens are huge they
actually can make their Sumo staples
into restaurants if they wanted to
everybody sleep on futons even that is
by ranking too so the higher rank could
have their own rules I had my own room
to sleep in but a lower ring they all
sleep in one room so it's real what you
just saw is exactly what happens
foreign
[Music]
a million percent right you have to be
the first to get up and get people stuff
prepared you got to be the last to go to
sleep because you're taking people's
stuff to wash and you got to make sure
everybody your senior guys have their
towels everything they need for practice
at the tongue before you go to sleep
they make it sound so nice bro I had
white floors from 3 30 in the morning
before I went to Sumo school for six
months I did that after sweeping on my
knees and you're not allowed to look
Mobsters like he has to use towels clean
all the toys take all the garbage out by
4 30 in the morning and then I walk to
school every single day you can put a 10
for this clip it's the real deal it's
like that's how life is
Jesus Christ as deep as making my nuts
rub together the best way to explain it
is like walking Lucky Charms people like
to come and touch some of those because
it gives them good luck so for pregnant
ladies they would actually go to get
their belly rubbed by Sumotori just to
have a healthy baby
they wouldn't even allow his socks on
the marshes the Sumo belt and everybody
has their their own colors for their top
rank they get to pick what silk color
they want to wrestle in this is called
sagari if you go to the Shinto you go to
any Temple or any shrines and if you
look on the top there's there's actually
uh straws that are being weaved and
that's what the Yokozuna would wear and
you'll see stuff sticking out so that
kind of represents like a god authori
which is a Shinto tempo
[Applause]
that's even impossible to grab the
middle the silk is so hard like it's
like a cup there's no way you can grab
that stuff that's why there's nothing
really real about it they built the
arena like the Arenas would look like
um outside of Tokyo all the bleachers
other stands custodial we have our own
stadium it's owned by the summer
Association but all they are like Osaka
in March they have uh July in a place
called Nagoya I give them two foot train
and the harmony comes from within the
balance will come back so
the only good thing about this whole
clip is the word that we use a lot in
the spirit and of sumo and where they
plan to to make you a high rank or
something they always the judges that
judge us would actually judge us on that
stinky tie what she's trying to explain
to girls have to get that spirit and
stuff but you don't really need that to
do the squats She's Doing It Wrong
herself too so if you look at a real
good squat there's a sumoto you notice
they are going straight up and down
their knee is not even coming forward
and stuff you have to transfer all your
weight to one side of your body extend
the knee that all your weight is on and
then lift your leg not easy everybody's
just lifting up your leg that's not the
exercise they do have some more women
sumo wrestlers in amateur level and it's
huge it's a huge sport in amateur level
the heavyweight ones are actually from
Japan and stuff so it's still prohibited
in professional assume it is they're not
allowed to even step on our Rings that's
why even our practice Rings didn't allow
ladies are not allowed onto the Rings oh
maybe a five four you can see she's
trying to score that so and give him
that much
it's like the conditioning part of sumo
which is what we call Scotty Keiko it's
one of the hardest exercise one guy
catches all the hits and what he does is
he see him putting the head down that is
to try to see get your opponent as tight
as you can and see if he can keep his
balance when we used to do this we
weren't allowed to show anybody the boss
would actually kick all the media out
that's how hardcore he was so what you
see is exactly what we do
when you renew the ring they do a
blessing and this is done every single
tournament every major tournament right
before they start they got uh what they
call Ika dry squid and they have sake
and they have I think rice and salt in
the middle of the ring there's a hole in
it that they put all that in there and
they cover it up before every tournament
so it's very ceremonial give it a 10.
this is a good one
oh this is kitao good acting but that's
guys it's a real grand champion so I
don't think if it was real this guy
would have get his ass kicked he's a six
seven 430 pound Sumotori we're the same
age we wrestled against each other a lot
because his background is Judo so
depending on how your body is built
there's techniques that you can use for
me I'm round and big and heavy so my
idea of finishing a match I have to
finish within five seconds that's my
goal
foreign
it's illegal to punch in Sumo so this is
not even a small match it has no
comparison it's just another WWE the
other rule that people don't know it's
like when you grab the hair by accident
if you touch the hair you lose the match
and the other thing if your belt get
loose and the judges around this five
judges around the ring can see your
Jingle Bells or your marbles hanging out
you lose your match
connected chop his jar you can actually
broker the nose and there's a lot of
guys who got ko'd right in the middle of
the Ring because of the chop zero
something like this would never happen
my favorite clip was
the actors getting boost cutting it
reminds me of the little villages in
Japan still today they love someone so
much they go out and teach as much as
they know to the younger kids and stuff
if you enjoyed this video guys you
better click click click or I'm gonna
come and someone stump you keep on
stopping
super style